Oh flappy birds yes Oh finally I get to
exact my revenge on you [ __ ] no not
finally are you do exact my revenge that
makes it much more that makes it I
didn't kill anyone but Italy said don't
kill your girlfriend no stop humping
each other and get over here
excuse me need to get into your pile of
orgy and go on my way cuz I have someone
important that needs my attention
someone very very close to me where's
where's my girlfriend don't move I
wonder why it tells me not to move thank
you everybody for warning me oh this one
will said kill them all I thought that
it was gonna be something else
you can't go kill them all that's not a
regular basis every day he murders
innocent civilians at any point nope cut
off your own balls with your own machete
that's too bad for you
oh no poorly your legs came right off Oh
flippin flappybird
I'll show you flappy bird you
actually hang on wait a single okay what
happened why can you survive hey wait
the finish line is over there oh okay
I survived that one I think someone
might have not oh I don't get a poon of
my ass oh that's okay I lost feeling
down there ages ago where am I going why
am I going there so quickly Oh
[Music]
meatball I haven't heard the word leet
in ages and ages and ages oh I get what
this is I've already lost my happy raw
goddamnit happy rope swings I'm so
smiley and unperceptive ly happy it's
impossible that I cannot be this happy
when I play this friggin rope swing I
don't think it's just what I supposed to
do
but I'm happy hahaha hello how about you
load I would love it if this level would
freakin load please load for K there was
a problem mm-hmm all true by chore wait
that's the first time that I would know
how thousand ways to die my god that's
what's called your doom 1004 that well
I've given you my kid as a sacrifice can
I get out of here welcome to your doom
again it's not like you haven't been
here a million no no no
No
let's go backwards come on okay just run
over the body of your long dead son and
carry on your way oh I love the raining
blood sugar hours of my butt Pogo ninja
test to start your test we'll go with a
simple spike fall okay
hold control not help me in any way
herb go with skill and go with skill and
grace okay good good good control
perfectly normal
rocket you ready son
we're gonna go for an adventurous ride
of epic proportions don't know where
we're going exactly or how we're gonna
land but yeah extremely hard my left
nipple on this level you get a load for
me
don't della load your level for bake dig
that we did Wow actually did BES such an
ass I get a second chances what god
[Music]
alright you kiddies just what's called
prepare to die so don't I mean you could
exert all these we prepared the time
because your life is rather not
voluble and then my life I think I'm
supposed to press Z or something at the
who can have a fun time a son a son I
don't know the voice would either what
do you expect from me wait oh yay cam
sparkles all right come with me honey
I won't lead you astray especially not
to our own death Oh right out of the
gate you douche I'm gonna go when I feel
like going none of my launched like a
rocket
lame box all right come along little
children we don't have long to die
let me this is really all I got left and
I mean it's practically cheating burr
I'm a helicopter guy oh you were right
they're coming for little fun oh my
goodness gravy how do I make the arrow
shoot how do I make the arrows go come
on come on come on get through here get
through here shoot the arrows damn it
why is everyone already dead white there
we go oh it's got it's frozen everything
oh my god everything is frozen so much
lag but I don't care oh go go go no no
no no impossible arrow run nothing is
impossible for me oh that is in my face
how long you got to keep shooting in my
head there yep okay nope dodge epic news
[Music]
[Music]
come on oh god damn it
Oh balls waffles plane the ball frame
the ball sward of gas who are we
[Music]
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you liked the
video and want to see more why not
subscribe today wanna help the channel
grow leave a light add it to your
favorites will share with your friends
on Facebook and Twitter thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video